so i'm going to give you two suggestions
one is all right and the other one is
kind of the it's the it's the killer
right for how to crack a cipher using
the caesar side okay here's our first
example now this is a message right
one of the problems with the way that we
have done this the way that we have
encrypted this is that we have preserved
spaces okay you notice that right so
what you've got is you can see oh
that's a um
that's a one letter word and this is a
four letter word and so on
so therefore
immediately i know
that this is really limited to very few
options what could it be
it could be a
or it could be i
right and you can probably guess like if
it's going to be a sentence it's more
likely to start with an i than an a but
even so you've only got two options so
you can automatically work out all right
it's going to be for example
it could have been a shift of two
or it could have been a shift of i don't
know what that is 20 20 something okay
so
that's that's a really quick way to do
this how would you avoid this by the way
how would you avoid something like this
two i've got two solutions number one
you could eliminate the spaces right so
you could transmit this
and then
presumably after it's decrypted if you
actually are the person who's the
intended recipient and you decrypt this
if the letters are right then you'll be
able to work out where the spaces go
okay fine
alternatively
you could treat the space
as another letter you could treat that
as letter number 27
and then you could shift this as well
right
now
that's a that's a clever way to do it
because what's going to happen is some
other letter like say m m is going to
become the space right so your new
message you'll have spaces and all these
awkward spots you'll be like what is
this message right so that's cool
but there's a problem okay
in any kind of um normal english right
like what's the average number of spaces
sorry average number of letters in
normal english like language
maybe five
maybe six well your things you've got a
lot of like one and two letter words so
they're kind of going to bring the app
down
yeah okay now the point is right
that means you're going to get spaces
very very regularly right so whatever
you shift the space to maybe you shift
the space to like the letter l or
something
l's are going to turn up everywhere and
it's going to be a real giveaway okay
that's the first problem that's sorry
second problem right
there's a much bigger problem much much
bigger so here's one way here's one clue
by how you can crack a cipher quickly
right but suppose the message you got
either had no spaces in it or it had no
one-letter words
okay well here is you're looking at
the other key to kraken okay now what is
this this is all of the 26 letters are
our alphabet right what i did was i got
about half the class to come up take
their original message in proper english
and then just tally against which
letters you used now here's the thing i
had zero knowledge
of what your messages were
but i knew
with almost like 99 accuracy certainty
i knew this was going to be the pattern
we would get this is a very familiar
pattern
which are the letters that are most
common they stand out don't they yep e
and i
you've got
a vowel
another vowel
this vowel is pretty bad too right this
one not so much and this one also but
that's because they're less common s
s
is by far the most common consonant
right and it always is
and in fact the more words you take the
more this pattern will emerge okay so
here's the thing if you have a like not
just uh what is this that's 11
characters 11 characters
if you have 11 characters it's kind of
anyone's guess
but if you have 11 000 characters
right
you're going to have a very predictable
frequency for for instance how much the
letter e is going to appear it's always
going to be the most common one
so you can make a very educated guess
right away suppose in the cipher text
the encrypted text the most common
letter is t
well what you would guess is that an e
was turned into a t so you'd say well
this is number five right and t is
number i don't know 20.
20 21. so then you would guess i'm
guessing it's plus 16
and then you'd see if that guess works
and it's not that hard to go through
20. okay so it's plus 15.
so there you go
a couple of clues for how to crack the
caesar cipher in the next few days
uh and weeks we're going to look at more
different ciphers and the kinds of
things the kinds of maths underneath it
okay